so brian stelter this is this potato
clown guy that's on cnn
he hosts a show called reliable sources
and this is their sunday news recap show
and i i kid you not you know i've always
been
sort of a student of the media of
tv and politics i always loved all this
stuff even
really it started when i was about 10
years old i sort of remember
when i was sort of into this stuff and
my dad would be watching these things
and i would be watching them
and it used to be reliable sources used
to be hosted by a guy
by the name of howard kurtz who now is
on fox news but it was basically
like they would talk about like what's
going on in the media what are our blind
spots
can we do something better can we really
hold power to account howard kurtz i
thought did a pretty nice
job doing it and he do he does a similar
show if i'm not mistaken on on fox these
days but anyway brian stelter took over
from him
i think it's probably about 10 years ago
or so something like that
and stelter is just awful if you want to
just see like the type of person that's
just part of the machine and just wants
to like suck up
to all of the worst people constantly
and when he thought things were horrible
under trump now the same things
happen under biden but you know we don't
talk about them anymore or we
somehow obfuscate them or whatever it
might be well first just listen
to this question you're going to get the
answer from pasaki but listen to the
question
that stelter asks pasaki here's clip one
what does the press get wrong when
covering
biden's agenda when you watch the news
when you read the news
what do you think we get wrong well
look i think some of our muscles have
atrophied a little bit over the last few
years
and there isn't a a lot of memory or
recent memory or long
longer memory on how long it takes to
get legislation forward
or how messy the process of negotiating
and the process of getting legislation
across the finish line
can be so we know we understand
everybody's always looking for a
deadline a timeline
things like that but at the end of the
day our focus is on
getting these bills across the finish
line doing it in a bipartisan way if we
can
and we certainly recognize that that can
be messy along the process so
i don't know if that's the press getting
it wrong i'll leave you to the critique
of that brian but
i think sometimes we forget uh how
strange the last four years were and
when we returned to a place where
democracy is working where we're talking
with democrats and republicans where
we're trying to get bills and
legislation passed
yes when we return to a place when
democracy is working when we're all
blowing each other constantly and nobody
is saying
anything remotely close to true i mean
forget her answer she's just she's just
the worst
but his question what does the press get
wrong why would you ask the press
secretary that
that's the person you're supposed to be
challenging that's the person who is the
face
of the white house every day out there
with the press that's the person you
should be asking
all the most incisive questions that's
the most the person you should be asking
all the most pressing questions that you
should be
pushing and prodding to get to something
closer to truth and he said
what does the press get wrong when
covering the biden agenda that is the
worst sort of oh
i mean they literally stelter is
basically a puppy who wants a cookie
that's all he is he's a little a fat
little puppy
who you know some puppies are you know
he got into the cookie jar too much but
he's just down there
like please can i have another cookie
can i have another cookie that's
i want a cookie all right if you didn't
think that was bad enough then
stelter asks pasaki because she's known
to speak
truth he asks her about truth
journalists who watch what you do what's
your advice for them about
trying to stay here close to the truth
in this world of lies
well i think what i try to do is stay
grounded to the facts
and what i mean by that the details and
what we can help
provide publicly to clarify context to
make it more understandable to the press
to the public
uh and it sometimes it's not more
complicated than that
oh lord give me the strength it's only
monday
forget again forget her answer she just
says words like it's just word word word
noun adjective adverb okay she's just
saying nothing but that's her job to say
nothing
um but asking the press secretary
about truth you
stelter you're one of the prime
purveyors of lies
you push the russia hoax the covington
kids hoax
the brett kavanaugh hoax we can go on
and on about the lies
that you push every week then there was
this other thing last week speaking of
stelter and his network cnn
where jake tapper said that he won't
have liars on his show anymore and he
was talking about a couple
republicans uh who were defending trump
you know over election stuff a few
months ago that he's not going to have
these liars
on his show anymore and then uh what's
her name stefanik what's what's her
first name elise
stefanik i believe uh who is a
congresswoman out of new york i think
maybe staten island if i'm not mistaken
she posted screenshots it's actually
spectacular of
tapper's people asking her to come on
the show at the same time while he's
saying he's not going to talk to these
people
they're all liars they're liars and
they're
it's as if they're like laundering the
lies with each other
so you get stelter talking to pasaki
it's his job to lie it's her job to lie
let's all launder the lies together and
we'll all lie
all the time and as i quote all the time
now this alternates in quote
we know that they know they're lying we
know they're lying
they know that we know they're lying and
they continue to lie
well it's just gonna keep going people
it is just bananas